bonjour à tous je suis c'est 'qui la
technique aujourd'hui je vais vous
expliquer ce qu'est la banque centrale
européenne alors c'est quoi la banque
centrale européenne
pour comprendre l'origine de la banque
centrale européenne il faut remonter à
la création de l'union européenne fondé
dans les années 90 grâce au traité de
maastricht l'union européenne est
composé de plusieurs pays ils ont pour
but de coopérer entre eux sur le plan
judiciaire et économique
il fallait donc créer une banque pour
gérer ce grand espace économique de la
haie mais la banque centrale européenne
mais pourquoi donc avoir créé une banque
pour l'europe en des grands principes de
l'europe et la mise en place d'une
monnaie unique l'euro afin d'éviter les
conflits ont les gonds la gestion de
cette monnaie un seul pays l'europe a
créé la banque centrale européenne qui
fonctionne seul et qui est donc quand
dépendante des autres institutions
européennes au niveau décisionnel
qu'économique et financier
et à quoi sert la banque centrale
européenne la banque centrale européenne
faire à gérer la monnaie de l'europe
elle veille à la stabilité des prix elle
fixe et les politiques budgétaires de
l'union européenne c'est-à-dire qu'elle
choisit les orientations économiques de
l'europe pour la rendre stable et
durable elle a aussi pour mission de
fabriquer l'euro et elle est la seule à
pouvoir le faire et de qui est composée
la banque centrale européenne la banque
centrale européenne est composé des
banques centrales nationales des pays
faisant partie de l'union européenne
chaque pays dispose de sa banque
centrale nationale
elles ont pour objectif d'observer les
différentes banques présentes sur le
pays et interviennent sur les décisions
à prendre au niveau de l'économie de
l'europe et qui prend les décisions à la
banque centrale européenne
ce sont les gouverneurs des banques
nationales c'est-à-dire lé président
ainsi que les membres de la direction de
la banque centrale européenne qui
prennent les décisions
ces dernières sont votés dureront le
conseil des gouverneurs j'espère que
vous avez bien compris ce qu'est la
banque centrale européenne à bientôt
pour un nouvel épisode